-Last night, even after
a violent insurrection
at the U.S. Capitol attempted to
overthrow American democracy,
a majority of Republicans
in the House
and a handful of GOP senators
tried to throw out the results
of the presidential election,
and now, the right-wing media
is already trying
to blame the left
for the sedition they sowed.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Yesterday, there was
a violent insurrection
and attempted sedition
in the United States,
and as we noted
on this show last night,
what we all witnessed was,
unfortunately,
a familiar part
of American history.
It's not all of what America is,
and, in fact, it's been rejected
by a majority of Americans
in election after election,
including in Georgia
on Tuesday,
but it is very much a part of
what America is,
and as we said
last night, as well,
there have been violent
white supremacist coups
in this country before --
like the mob riot
in Wilmington,
North Carolina, in 1898
that overthrew a
legitimately elected
biracial government.
No one ever learns that stuff
in history class
because our textbooks
whitewash it.
In fact, I'm pretty sure
my history textbook
jumped from the end
of the Civil War
to the Great Depression,
and the chapter in between
was just called
"Yada Yada Yada."
And if you want to step outside
the bubble of American media
for just a moment and get
a truly harrowing look
at the state of our democracy
from the vantage point
of the rest of the world,
take a few minutes
to watch this report
from a British
television network
on the violence at the Capitol.
-The pro-Trump crowd
fought with the police.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Hey!
-Trying to break
through their lines...
[ Shouting continues ]
...intoxicated by
the unlikely prospect
of reversing America's
election outcome.
This is exactly
what was feared,
but in no way
is this a surprise.
It has been fueled by
the president's rhetoric.
We follow the aggrieved
and infuriated Trump supporters
as they stormed the building...
-I swear that's CNN,
and they just said these guys...
-...through broken windows
and doors
they had forced open,
and for a few heady moments,
they felt they had won
a precious victory.
America's long journey
as a stable democracy
appears to be
in genuine doubt.
-Wow, that is sobering.
Nothing opens your eyes
like hearing a British person
breathlessly describe
your bad behavior.
Like, I think I'm a pretty good
dad and husband,
but I wouldn't if I heard
the BBC say,
[ British accent ] "Sunday
morning, and he's still in bed,
his wife downstairs
making breakfast for his sons.
He knows he could
provide assistance,
yet he idly scrolls
through his Twitter feed.
Looking for what?
Even he doesn't know."
[ Normal voice ] So, can
politicians and the media
stop using the words
"banana republic"
or "third world country"
to describe
what happened yesterday?
Please?
I mean, there have been
violent insurrections
in this country before
and without consequences,
and it's gonna happen again.
That's why the people
responsible for this violence
must be held accountable
from the top down.
They should be removed
from the White House
and expelled from Congress.
The FBI, for its part,
announced that they are seeking
to identify individuals
instigating violence
in Washington, D.C..
"We are accepting tips
and digital media
depicting rioting or violence
in and around the
U.S. Capitol on January 6."
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh!
Ohhh!
I have a tip!
-We will never give up!
We will never concede!
You have to get
your people to fight.
We're gonna walk down
to the Capitol...
[ Cheering ]
...and we're gonna cheer on
our brave senators
and congressmen and women,
and we're probably not
gonna be cheering so much
for some of them...
[ Laughter ]
...because you'll never take
back our country with weakness.
You have to show strength,
and you have to be strong.
-If we're right,
a lot of them
will go to jail.
[ Cheering ]
So...
...let's have trial by combat!
-Hey, FBI, you might want
to check that guy out.
I remember seeing him around
New York a few years back.
Randy-something?
No, Rudy!
President's lawyer
told a crowd of supporters
he wants a trial by combat.
But sure, we're the ones
being hysterical
by calling this a coup.
Also, trial by combat.
I knew Rudy was born
in the '40s,
but I didn't think
it was the 1440s.
"The last time I engaged
in trial by combat
was with Henry the IV.
That's when I died
the first time!"
What would a medieval trial by
combat even look like with Rudy?
He probably keeps his
broadsword in his pants.
"Oh, is the fight starting?
Help me with the zipper, honey."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, imagine...
imagine being such
a Trump dead-ender
that you're pinning
your hopes on a guy
who got duped
by Borat's daughter.
Although, I will admit,
yesterday,
even I was inspired
when I heard the song
that played
when Rudy entered the rally.
-♪ Macho, macho man ♪
♪ Macho, macho man ♪
♪ I've got to be a macho ♪
-Do we really believe
these people know
the intricacies
of the Constitution
when they don't know
the context of "Macho Man"?
And then yesterday,
Rudy sunk even lower
after the insurrection,
when he called up newly-elected
Alabama Senator Tommy Tuberville
and asked him to keep
challenging states
to stop
the certification process.
Or at least, he thought
he was calling Tuberville.
It turns out Rudy accidentally
dialed up a different senator,
and then that senator
released it.
-Oh, Rudy.
Even when he's trying
to foment a violent coup,
he's also America's
dumbest potato goblin.
First Four Seasons
Total Landscaping, now this.
Also, how could he have mixed up
the name "Tuberville"
with a different senator?
The name sounds like
a children's cartoon character.
"Meet the Tubervilles"
sounds like the name of a movie
where Eddie Murphy will play
everyone in the family,
and that movie would be great.
And I know there's a lot going
on and this isn't for today,
but Eddie Murphy deserved
an Oscar for "Nutty Professor."
Also, this Rudy story
is a useful reminder
that just because these
people are brain-dead morons
with sludge in their skulls
doesn't mean they're not also
violent seditionists.
It can be a coup,
even though most of the people
leading the coup are dumb.
I'm pretty sure there
were also some
real [bleep] dip[bleep]
in the Confederacy, too.
I mean, there's a base named
after Confederate
General Braxton Bragg,
who, in addition to being
a slaver and a traitor,
was also "a jackass and an
ass[bleep]," "a bad strategist,
an inept tactician,
a racist and a screw-up."
He'd fit right in
with the Trump crowd.
Did he also get
pranked by Borat
and send telegrams
to the wrong generals?
"This is Braxton Bragg.
We're staging a secret nighttime
assault in Chattanooga.
Don't tell anyone."
"Um, this is Ulysses S. Grant."
"Oh, no. Damn it!
Oh, you screwed up again,
Braxton."
So it shouldn't surprise us
that some of the guys leading
this current insurrection
against the United States
are also some of
the dumbest ass[bleep] alive.
You've got Trump, Rudy, and
Arizona Congressman Paul Gosar,
the first guy to object to
Arizona's electoral
votes yesterday,
who announced even
after the insurrection
that he'd be continuing
with his objections,
which were joined,
it should be noted,
by over 120 House Republicans,
the majority of the GOP caucus.
You might remember
Gosar is the guy
whose siblings aired an ad
for his Democratic opponent
in 2018.
And not just one of them
or two of them -- six.
Six of his siblings
openly campaigned against him.
Do you know how
humiliating that is?
That's like if my entire family
went on James Corden's
Thanksgiving show.
You have a contract, Dad.
Also, lock up your gin, James.
And here's a question for Gosar,
since he's from Arizona,
but he's also challenging
the Arizona results --
and this applies to Republicans
from Pennsylvania
and Georgia and Michigan and all
the other swing states --
if the presidential election
was fraudulent,
how come your election
wasn't fraudulent?
Why did you take your seat
if the results from your
state can't be trusted?
It's the same ballot. Literally
the same piece of paper.
These guys are like diners
complaining to a waiter
that the chicken isn't cooked,
and when the waiter asks
if they want something else,
they say, "Yeah, some more
of this raw-ass chicken."
It just shows that
their arguments
are obvious bull[bleep]
It's just a lie to conceal
their true aim --
overthrowing democracy and
installing Trump as a dictator.
And there should be
immediate consequences for that,
which is why it was,
quite frankly,
head-spinning and a little
bizarre to watch members
of the House and Senate return
to their chambers yesterday
after the violence and act
as if nothing had happened.
-The center of America
is not Washington, D.C.
The center of America
is the neighborhoods
where 330 million Americans
are raising their kids and
trying to put food on the table
and trying to love
their neighbor.
Organize, persuade,
but most importantly,
love your neighbor.
Visit the widower down
the street who's lonely
and didn't want to tell
anybody that his wife died
and he doesn't have
a lot of friends.
Shovel somebody's neighbor --
shovel somebody's driveway.
You can't hate somebody who
just shoveled your driveway.
-Oh, yes, you can.
Two 16-year-old punks
from down the street
kindly offered to shovel
my driveway last week,
so I said, "Oh, that's so nice."
And then an hour later,
they came back to my door
and said, "Okay,
that'll be 50 bucks."
And I said, "50 bucks? I thought
this was a community service."
And they said, "Stubborn,
old man, where's our money?"
And I said, "I'm not old!"
And they said, "1973 called.
They want their haircut back."
And I said, "Where'd you learn
that joke formation from?
It hasn't been in style
for years."
But they just
high-fived each other
and started shoveling the snow
back onto my driveway,
so I chased after them,
but then I fell and I hurt
my back and I couldn't get up.
So I had to beg them
to help me up,
and they say they would
do it for 100 bucks.
And I said, "No way!"
So then they started
shoveling snow on top of me
and said, "Now it's $200," and
long story short, I'm old.
Also, quick follow-up question
for you, Ben Sasse.
What a-the [bleep] are you
a-talking about?
Violent separatists just
ransacked the Capitol
in an attempt
to overthrow democracy,
forcing lawmakers and staff
to lock down
and shelter in place,
and your solution is to shovel
your neighbor's driveway?
This isn't Lake Wobegon.
You're not the host
of "Prairie Home Companion."
You're a United States senator,
and insurgents
just breached the Capitol!
Also, I'm sorry,
from your story,
who is this widower
that doesn't want to tell
anyone his wife died?
That sounds super shady, Ben.
And if he hasn't told anyone,
does that mean
I don't know he's a widower
when I go and visit?
Am I trying to find out
over the course of the visit?
"Where's Edith?"
"I don't know.
Attic, maybe?
Uh, maybe basement?"
Does he need me to shovel
his driveway
because he's tired
from already shoveling?
"What were you doing
in your flower bed in January?"
"Oh! Don't go over there!"
I feel like that's a bit
of a tangent,
but so the [bleep] was that!
Ben Sasse sucks.
Why isn't Congress immediately
convening to remove the leader
of a violent insurrectionist
movement from the presidency?
He's an urgent
national security threat.
Thankfully, Democratic leaders
and many Republicans
have now started to announce
their support
for Trump's immediate
removal from office.
But it's not just Trump.
Today, he was cheered
by the RNC.
And even after yesterday's
events at the Capitol,
a majority of House Republicans
and several GOP senators
doubled down
on their attempt
to throw out the results
of the presidential election.
They went ahead with the same
goal as the separatists.
One of the ringleaders,
Josh Holley,
actually got up
on the Senate floor
and continued to insist
on his objections
even after a mob
ransacked the Capitol.
-I hope that this body
will not miss the opportunity
to take affirmative action
to address the concerns of
so many millions of Americans.
We do need an investigation
into irregularities, fraud.
This is the forum.
The Pennsylvania Supreme Court
hasn't heard the case.
There's no other court to go to
to hear the case in the state.
And so this is
the appropriate place
for these concerns to be raised,
which is why I have
raised them here today.
Got to say, I'm getting real
Patrick Bateman vibes
from this guy,
which is a bummer,
because based on Twitter,
a lot of people
are getting real
Seth Meyers vibes from him.
You have to be a real cretin
to not even evince
a scintilla of regret
for your role in the attempted
violent destruction
of democracy.
The only enjoyable part
of Hawley's speech
was watching Mitt Romney
right behind him,
trying as hard as he could
to shoot literal daggers
out of his eyes.
Do you know
how awful you have to be
to make Mitt Romney mad?
Say what you will about the guy,
but he's not exactly known
for his temper.
He's like the youth pastor
who lets you off the hook
for smoking weed.
"Well, if you guys say
it's medicinal, I trust you."
Trump should be removed
from office immediately.
Hawley, Cruz, and the rest
of the Sedition Caucus
should be expelled from
Congress, shamed and disgraced.
They should be remembered
in history forever
as seditionists
who attempted a coup.
And in Cruz's case,
he should also be remembered
as looking like
an alcoholic werewolf
who got stuck halfway
between transformations.
"There was a full moon,
but then it got cloudy.
But don't worry,
I'm suing the cloud."
Yet instead of wearing the shame
they deserve
and slinking away in disgrace,
many of the well-paid
provocateurs
in the right-wing media
who have spent years fomenting
the lies and conspiracy theories
that led to the moment,
they're doubling down
by repeating the gross
and baseless lie
that it actually
wasn't Trump supporters
who stormed the Capitol --
it was Antifa.
-Some of the people who breached
the Capitol today
were not Trump supporters.
They were masquerading
as Trump supporters
and in fact were members
of the violent terrorist group
Antifa.
-There are some reports
that Antifa sympathizers
may have been sprinkled
throughout the crowd.
-There's always bad actors that
will infiltrate large crowds.
I don't care if they're
radical left, radical right --
I don't know who they are.
They're not people
I would support.
-We don't know who all were
the instigators in this
of these horrible things
that happened today.
I think a lot of it
is the Antifa folks.
-There is some indication
that fascist Antifa elements
were involved,
that they embedded themselves
in the Trump protest
to appear to be
Trump protesters.
-The rumor is that even possibly
Antifa insurrectionists
possibly could have infiltrated
some of these movements
and maybe instigated
some of this.
-Their faces are on camera,
you ass[bleep]
Some of them were quoted
on the record in newspapers.
Also, why are you
repeating a rumor?
And where did you hear
the rumor, anyway?
Did Rudy accidentally
leave you a voicemail, too?
Also, it turns out
the story Gaetz based his line
of bull[bleep] on
was, of course, also bull[bleep]
and has since been retracted.
It turns out the facial
recognition software
the rumor was based on
actually identified two members
of neo-Nazi organizations
and a QAnon supporter
among the pro-Trump mob,
not Antifa members.
Oh, well, that's a little bit
of an oops, isn't it?
Innocent mistake,
and I'm sure Gaetz
and all the craven
Fox News ghouls
who repeated this disgusting lie
to defend a violent insurrection
will immediately apologize.
Who was running the facial
recognition software, anyway?
Oh, no.
Was it Rudy again?
"I used it on myself,
and I got a perfect match."
And really, of all people,
you think we want to hear
from Sarah Palin right now?
I mean, how'd you book her?
I figured she'd be
too busy writing a speech
via magnetic poetry
on her fridge.
"Antifa scoundrels were so
and always America hockey mom
you betcha!"
It is an urgent matter
of national security
and essential for the
preservation of our democracy
that Trump be lawfully removed
from office
as quickly as possible.
And if you're
in the administration
and you're choosing now
to resign with two weeks to go
instead of helping facilitate
his removal through impeachment
or the 25th Amendment,
then all you're doing
is looking out for yourself.
It needs to happen immediately,
along with the expulsion
or resignation of Cruz,
Hawley,
and any other Republicans
who fomented this violent
sedition against our democracy.
If this isn't a moment
that calls for urgent
congressional action,
then nothing is.
Congress, put as much effort
into this
as you would if you were about
to, I don't know...
-Shovel somebody's driveway.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.